the dixie fire continues to grow after  reducing yet another northern california  community  to ashes it's the biggest wildfire now  burning in the state  and it's the third largest on record in  less than 24 hours the dixie fire  wiped the historic gold rush town of  greenville and nearby kainen dam  off the map this is what the fire looked  like thursday night on the road two  canyon dam  everything trees cars homes up in flames  officials believe this fire will  continue to burn for several been  fighting fire for  almost 25 years and this is the most  extreme fire behavior that i've ever  been a part of  smoke from western wildfires is pushing  into the bay area and was seen as far  east as salt lake city utah